après le refus honteux du gouvernement
néo-fasciste italien la France se devait
être au rendez-vous et nous l'avons
salué pendant que d'autres adeptes de la
théorie du Grand remplacement aurait
souhaité qu'on les abandonne attention
bien sûr qui se porte toujours sur le
sort des migrants demandeurs d'asile
dans le Var plusieurs ont vu leur
demande accepter d'autres sont toujours
en attente alors qu'il est et certains
ont même pu sortir de ce qu'on appelle
la zone d'attente internationale ces
bateaux ne font pas de sauvetage en mer
ces navires au rendez-vous au milieu de
la mer Méditerranée avec les passeurs
qui emmènent les migrants et les faux
monter à bord des navires humanitaires
on est soumis aujourd'hui un appel d'air
voulu par Emmanuel Macron qui fait que
des Ocean Vikings il y en aura de plus
en plus le rapport 2021 de l'agence
Frontex et sans équivoque les migrants
venus de libides déclarent constamment
vérifier la présence des ONG avant leur
départ expliquant je cite quand
l'absence de ces navires beaucoup
refusent de partir les trafiquants
d'êtres humains ont gagné
les ONG sont leurs complices
idéologiques et désormais vous aussi la
vérité la vérité c'est que nous avons
secouru des femmes et les enfants que
malheureusement l'Italie n'a pas voulu
secourir la vérité madame la députée
c'est que nous avons fait preuve
d'humanisme quand vous faites de la
politique politicienne quand on a ce
phénomène démographique absolument
insoutenable et qu'on voit cette volonté
massive des jeunes populations
africaines de venir en Europe il était
parfaitement irresponsable d'envoyer un
nouveau signal à travers l'accueil de
l'océan Viking vous n'êtes pas apte au
pouvoir parce que vous n'êtes pas
t'apprendre des décisions difficiles en
regardant les Français dans les yeux et
je m'endorgueille madame la députée que
soit cette majorité qui soit pouvoir
pour sauver ses enfants là avec vous on
sait ce qui serait devenu alors lui
je t'emmerde je m'en bats les couilles
etc voilà on parle comme ça un député
imaginez-vous l'inverse
imaginez-vous que ce soit Louis qui est
parlé comme ça qu'est-ce qu'on aurait
pas dit de l'insoumi s'il y a eu pour
tort de critiquer les activités de
Monsieur Bolloré en Afrique sur une
chaîne de la chaîne C8
a complètement perdu ses moyens a
complètement perdu son calme et son
sang-froid et s'est mis à insulter
monsieur Boyard se faire donner des
leçons si vous voulez de bien séance par
la France insoumise c'est quand même
relativement drôle parce que il passe
leur vie eux à insulter leurs
adversaires politiques il y a eu des
insultes c'est un fait il existe aussi
l'excuse de provocation et moi je
faisais balance ton poste en dernier il
était là Louis Boyard et c'est quelqu'un
qui ne pense en fait qu'à une seule
chose lui lui est reluie une question
qui est la question de
l'hyperconcentration des médias quand
vous avez 90% des médias qui sont
possédés par 9 personnes ça pose un
problème démocratique quand on voit
l'importance qu'on les médias dans notre
vie c'est une question qui se pose dans
le groupe de Vincent Bolloré
vis-à-vis de dry comme se pose à essayer
vis-à-vis Bouygues comme il se pose au
point vis-à-vis de Pinault que mes amis
du point je voudrais pas ne pas les
signer dans le service public vis-à-vis
de l'État effectivement et effectivement
c'est pas simple non plus de dire du mal
de Macron quand on est parfois sur le
service public c'est vrai mais monsieur
Boyard a été payé par cette chaîne
manifestement beaucoup
il a dans son parcours aussi justifié le
trafic de drogue en disant qu'il en
avait lui-même participé donc je le
redis pour être respecté il faut être
respectable je crois que c'est pas le
cas de Monsieur Boyard autre débat qui
rebondit aujourd'hui faut-il ou non
interdire la corrida la question
s'invite à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
une première car une proposition de loi
d'un député à de la France insoumise
sera déposé demain dans le sud de la
France qui fait partie de cette culture
occitane qui la connaît bien
vous assurer une chose ça n'a jamais
fait partie de la culture occitane que
de pratiquer la corrida que l'on
reconnaisse aujourd'hui qu'il est
désormais interdit de torturer
publiquement un animal de le mettre à
mort publiquement d'en faire un
spectacle de plaisir et bien ça
acte quelque chose de très fort pour
nous dans notre rapport à l'animal je
vais voter contre cette interdiction de
loi
qui vise à interdire la corrida oui on
tue des bêtes oui monsieur Caron et on
les mange laissez-moi manger ma viande
je vous empêche pas de manger vos
pissenlits monsieur Caron